basically someone somewhere is getting
married here comes the pretty little
bride that's right there is a PLL
wedding cunning in season seven but the
question is which liar will be walking
down the aisle
only et caught up with the stars on set
and asked them to plan their characters
dream wedding
I think if train would have planned
Spencer in Caleb's dream wedding I think
it would be an elopement I think they
would go back to Barcelona and they
would get married in some I mean maybe
even like one of the museums and then
the girls could come over and then they
could kind of have like a whole group
like Euro Train kind of like hit all the
big European cities if it were Spencer
and Toby I think that they would get
married somewhere like like Big Sur or
in like the Appalachian Mountains and I
think it would be a really really small
ceremony then I think that probably how
they would get there would be like they
would be building a house together like
a cabin in the woods and then at the end
of building the cabin they would
celebrate by opening it up to everybody
that they love and having a wedding
there and like beginning their lives
there and playing Scrabble at the same
time Scrabble and Leslie I also thank
you on our wedding night they just like
Scrabble what would Emily's ideal
wedding be plan this with me
I honestly think it'd probably be like
somewhere on a beach I think she would
go barefoot I don't know what she'd wear
maybe like an all-white cool like
three-piece ooh for like ooh ha ha ha ha
um I don't know I just I think it would
be somewhere on a beach very relaxed if
you were Hannah's wedding
hopefully the Caleb I think it'd be
super cool she's like in fashion they
started their next chapter of their
lives in New York going all out like
something at the Met would be super cool
I think it has to be like super super
big ton of people like really fancy and
like just like cool like the best
wedding something wrong because she's
she's very loud with her clothes and her
life but I feel like deep down like her
morals and what she wants out of like
she's very simple and Ezra's very simple
um so I feel like it'd be small feel
like it'd be intimate
I'm not feeling like barnyard wedding
vibes very romantic intimate simple
lovely yeah okay so you think about me
like Roderick twinkle light like rustic
yes you feel me you know exactly what
I'm saying I like I like I know a
wedding planner if you end up needing
what you know who to call you my girl
okay for sure right
et will plan the way good to have good
to know